como cada 15 de mayo y los palestinos
recuerdan como en 1948 fueron expulsados
de sus tierras tras la guerra
árabe-israelí y la creación del estado
de israel entonces 700.000 personas
fueron forzadas al exilio ya convertirse
en desplazados sin embargo esta nakba o
catástrofe continúa para 5.7 millones de
refugiados palestinos según la onu que
están repartidos entre gaza cisjordania
jordania líbano y siria mientras el acto
principal se centra en ramala aquí en la
ciudad vieja de jerusalén este 74
aniversario se vive con tensión
empezando por los ingresos de judíos a
la explanada de las mezquitas algo que
ha reforzado la arenga de hamás a
defender al aqsa de la ocupación israelí
citando al portavoz del grupo el
asesinato de la periodista palestino
estadounidenses irina bucle hace cuatro
días y el ataque a su funeral aviva en
esta nakba sobre todo cuando la policía
israelí ha afirmado que no habrá
acciones disciplinarias contra los
oficiales que reprimieron el cortejo
fúnebre sobre esto y mientras las
investigaciones prosiguen el primer
ministro israelí naftalí bennett
prometió que las fuerzas y seguirán su
campaña contra el terrorismo sin
mencionar a bucle a este contexto se
suma que sólo esta semana israel aprobó
4.000 nuevas viviendas en asentamientos
en cisjordania ocupada y que comenzaron
los desalojos en las poblaciones de
massaguer ya está en el sur de hebrón
donde unos 1.300 palestinos corren
riesgo de ser expulsados